they had posited themselves as being
ready for that moment and there was
something akin to a
system failure
that happened in that group of friends
to a point where you can now count on
on on one hand with fingers spare who
actually addressed the code stuff
and i'm not it's not a personal thing
for me it's a disappointing thing for me
that because it's the kind of moment
where
at the moment we needed it the most
it needed to have happened
there is no more important moment than
this death star right this is this has
been
and i'm going to say something and i'm
going to repeat this i love you all
these friends know who i'm talking about
you miss the [ __ ] boat
and they might think i'm stupid nah man
they missed the boat you didn't
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i of course am dr brett
weinstein and i am a lucky person
uh i am sitting today with mahdi noise
one of the world's most courageous and
interesting people bro i'm going to say
this officially on your podcast man i
texted it to you the other day but i
love you too i love you too and i really
appreciate what you've been up to um i
know how incredibly difficult it is
obviously i've been involved in the same
battle you have been
exposed to some particularly brutal
criticism in that process and
um you got unceremoniously
thrown out of your profession your your
source of income
by an employer with whom you had a
contract that they violated prematurely
ended yeah uh well that's subject to
legal action i can't really go into the
details there but the summary is fair i
was in chronological order i was uh
i
the moment happened when i publicly said
i was no longer going to take a booster
and i gave my reasoning i've mentioned
this to you in private before but the
reasoning is as follows it's quite clear
for me and i don't see anybody how
anybody could find a problem with the
reasoning as i laid out on my social
feeds but also the history is all there
to check
um
you know i was injected in prison
now i'm a prisoner of conscience so by
definition anything done to me prison is
against my will
i don't know what they injected with me
till this day so i took a stance having
voluntarily taken
two jabs at the early stages when the uh
finally when the four-year-olds were
allowed to take it
because for me not that i trusted in
anything but for me being jabbed my
whole life by systems
uh a friend of mine once said it's like
you know when somebody's a rape victim
and and their definition of normal is
fluctuates i mean for me it was just
like oh let me get it out the way i did
it and i did it and i thought you know
what fine
but i'm never gonna
surrender the idea that lockdowns are
ever justified this was before the
mandates began
and then i went along and my critique
and my concern was only with lockdowns
and then suddenly you start learning
that people are saying no jab no job
and then they say there's a booster shot
that you have to take combined with no
jab no job and you're in a situation now
because the very definition of coercion
isn't i put a gun to your head when it
comes to medical procedures i don't need
a gun to your head coercion look at um
the universal declaration of human
rights and bioethics i think is article
6 if memory serves me correctly and you
look at the definition of consent
in there and there's absolutely it
states this explicitly that no negative
repercussion
should come at you for you refusing
consent that's what it means for you to
own your own consent that you're not
punished for exercising it otherwise
that's not consent by definition that's
coercion so no jab no job for me became
a crime against humanity and so the word
i used was deliberately in that context
i said i'm a conscientious objector to
vaccine mandates and will not be taking
one myself
and that was
you know
it reminded me what they then did to me
i mean it began a media campaign i was
called you measures called all sorts of
things and it end ended with
it ended and culminated with in
chronological order a premature
termination of my contract on the
largest commercial
radio station in the uk with a show that
on the weekends was getting over half a
million listeners regularly during a
lunchtime slot on saturdays and sundays
and all of it was live
it was a beautiful
relationship with the public that was
terminated prematurely
over a moral objection now that in
hindsight those people should be ashamed
those people that came for me at that
moment in hindsight why should they be
ashamed because
we've now learned from the vaccine data
you go from let's start in in in
chronological order of the way in which
the dominoes fell let's start with
astrazeneca april last year when
astrazeneca themselves in the bbc
reports this admitted that under 30s
should not take their vaccine because of
blood clots
fine everyone started taking johnson
johnson moderna pfizer a week later
astrazeneca said uh-oh under 40
shouldn't take it either this is last
year right this year april moderna has
to recall thousands and thousands of
vials of their vaccine because direct
quote foreign contaminant is in the
viles right after that this month
johnson johnson gets restricted by the
cdc because another thing blood clots
the same thing keeps propping up again
and again blood clots the only one left
then became pfizer and as we know from
the data that's just been dumped because
a judge had to order them to release the
data as opposed to them wanting to after
75 years that data tells us that over 1
200 people
died
in the first three months of their trial
now
what i want to know is i don't
say that that's a causal link
there's a correlation there what i want
to know is how can you define consent if
i'm not informed of that correlation
yeah and uh you know it is not only
coercive it is a clear violation of
nuremberg right there are many things
about that's why i said crime against
humanity it is a crime against humanity
and i would point out that there are
several insidious features here right so
on the one hand you have a so-called
vaccine and you and i have just been at
a conference where many people uh made
the point that actually that definition
is being so loosely used here that it's
it's counterproductive but these
so-called vaccines are
mysterious in their content and the idea
that people have in any way the
information with which to make an
informed choice is preposterous
but the other thing is that because of
these mandates
you have a violation of the idea that
you are obligated to reject immoral
orders right many people administered
these shots to people who they knew did
not have the information to make an
informed consent and anybody who didn't
administer the shots who was in those
positions was very likely to lose their
jobs so
um that is
entirely disturbing it's two violations
of nuremberg right it's the immoral
orders uh portion and the informed
consent portion and then the consequence
of it i find even more terrifying yeah
but i'm going to add
i'm going to add a point if i may yeah
so the violation isn't just by those
that perpetrated it and i believe you
this is neurabird level this is why i
use the words crime against humanity and
i said i became a conscientious objector
because this is war crime level stuff
and it's not just the perpetrators when
you start talking on that level and i'm
believe me i think we're there right
when you start talking on that level
anybody that propagated defended
supported
i was following orders no longer cuts it
when you're on that level of a crime it
doesn't cut it so anyone anyone that was
out there after being told this is the
problem and began hunting those that
were unvaccinated through their media
representations supporting things such
as lockdown only for the unvaccinated
supporting things like uh telling the
unvaccinated they cannot work
right that's a participation in the
crime and those people are also
responsible and and it will not cut it
to say i was following orders yes the
coercion was insidious and it was
extremely broad it came in every form
from interrupting your capacity to earn
to
your social group being manipulated into
pressuring right
and
it's
truly frightening in its own right but
i'm concerned actually
about what happens
one step down the road because what i
saw
was
a
what appears to me to be a very clever
move on the part of whatever this force
is that is that is doing these things in
which in one fell swoop they managed to
remove
all the people who were likely to object
right on the basis that those people
were going to object to their own
injections
of a substance that they didn't know
much about
that those people would eliminate
themselves from the ranks of our
security services of our military of our
universities and the problem is that
that leaves all of the institutions
in
basically staffed by people who don't
know that they are obligated to reject
immoral orders right that was that's a
genius level move and what it does is it
sets us up for the next tragedy of
history and i don't know what that
tragedy of history is going to look like
but i do know that we just got a lot
more likely to see it so i uh
i tweeted something related to what
you're just saying if i can read it and
then just uh i think because it links to
this point and then i can just tell you
what i was thinking when when i said
this
i
put this out yesterday so the the
optimum way to win this war against
humanity is to convince humans they are
not being warned upon
premium meat is wagyu the cow is
pampered until it is slaughtered if you
see but cannot perceive step aside so
that those of us who are awake may fight
this enemy for you i believe the
situation is that serious what you just
said there about staffing institutions
with people that no longer have the
uh the capacity to make moral judgments
and justify their actions by following
orders
you've got a situation that
how you create those people we have to
be aware that we're witnessing the
creation of that class
and so the cultural debates that are
happening in society at the moment part
of the
uh i'm going to summarize it in my
opinion part of the
how i see it is the deliberate
encouraging of narcissism in society so
that everybody is atomized right
it destroys community and if you destroy
a community there's no way because a big
part of those moral judgments come from
community now i don't care what form
that community looks like it's why i'm
not anti-theist right it's why i'm not
anti-religion that community could be a
mosque it could be a synagogue it could
be a church equally it could be a yoga
center equally it could be a sikh temple
or hindu temple it doesn't have to be
religious at all it could be the local
humanist chapter but that sense of
communities where people share moral
reflections and then and then find
solidarity in the communities more race
yeah that they go about sort of then
openly having the courage to speak about
that's how you get people that speak
because they feel they have a moral sort
of fabric supporting them coming from
their community if you don't have that
if you're atomized if you're living in a
shoebox in a city
you don't have the courage to speak
about anything you don't because you're
not connected to anything in the first
place the whole idea of speaking up
seems a very abstract notion for
somebody that is living in the
equivalent of a chicken in a cage right
which is the kind of architecture that's
now being encouraged in the kind of
architecture i've grown up through
london living in
and i think that so back to that point
about staffing these institutions
we have to we have to look
people in your position who who look at
things from a bird's eye perspective
my view would be that we have to look
culturally at the entire scene and note
across
in an interdisciplinary way where
certain behavior patterns are
encouraging this problem of people
becoming unable or incapable of making
moral decisions for the betterment of
humanity and if that means as roger
scruton used to do talking about
architecture but if that means you know
talking about holistic lifestyles or if
it means having this kind of more sort
of intellectual uh conversation but
ultimately we've got to be aware of
where this is happening in multiple
sectors because it's an honor society
problem in my view you know and we've
just witnessed how where there's an
order society failure look what just
happened i mean i i'm hoping people
agree with us by now it was a failure
well uh you know some do and some don't
yet have ears to hear or don't have the
freedom so what do you think is going on
there i think a number of things are
going on i mean i would say you're
correct that a kind of narcissism has
been encouraged i would also point to
solipsism and
maybe most critically sophistry many of
the arguments that we are up against are
um
so obviously wrong but so difficult to
um
to dismantle that anyway we we spin our
wheels explaining things that shouldn't
need any explanation
at all
on your point about community i would
point out that there's another feature
of this as well which is
things
that have nothing to do with the failure
we've just seen have disconnected people
from
each other and not just in sort of a
vague way
the fact that
many things downstream of birth control
and technological aspects of dating and
changes in the the mores surrounding sex
and romance have caused people not to
prioritize
the finding of a mate see i had to come
back around to this what you're saying i
agree with you but i had to come back
around to it because i had a after my
divorce you know when i got out of
prison my marriage broke up yeah
and i
i don't know how much of it is what
normally happens to a guy that's
heartbroken or how much of it was my
fault but there were many there was a
journey i had to make to get back to
this point and sorry to interrupt you
but i wholeheartedly agree with you that
on this point actually and people don't
realize the value of it
this episode is brought to you by
american hartford gold
inflation is at its highest level in 40
years interest rates are skyrocketing
we are caught between runaway inflation
and a recession our retirement accounts
are in real danger
if you want to protect your future call
american hartford gold and let them show
you how to protect your savings and
retirement accounts by diversifying your
portfolio with physical gold and silver
they make it easy but you will need a
phone
all it takes to get started is a short
call and they'll have physical gold and
silver delivered right to your door or
inside your ira or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an a plus rating from the
better business bureau and thousands of
satisfied customers
call them now they will give you up to
fifteen hundred dollars of free silver
on your first qualifying order
call american hartford gold at eight six
six eight two eight one one one seven
that's eight six six eight two eight one
one one seven or text dark horse to nine
nine eight
nine
the value is almost indescribable and i
know that you know as much as i have
placed a value on this since i was very
young i didn't understand the full value
until i saw what they did to us during
covet right because so you've also
recently had a reinforcement of this for
yourself absolutely i mean i had an
intuitive sense of how important this
was and it had been important in my life
in many different ways
however what i didn't understand was
that the chances that you were going to
hang on to your sanity
if you and your partner were watching
the same movie right i don't care
how many people swear that you've lost
your mind if somebody that you know
well can sit down and look you in the
eye and say you know what i don't know
what they're talking about but i see it
too right what you're saying is not
crazy here's the part i don't agree with
right they'll tell you what they don't
agree with but the the reality check
being a primary feature of your life was
one of the things that
made it possible to not be sucked into
this intense gravitational well that was
set up by the mainstream narrative and
it really
couldn't have been more important and
what's more
i i don't know whether you've had this
experience
among the most common things that people
say to me and this has not been
uh
years this has been
six months among the most common things
that people say to me when they stop me
on the street is
keep going you are keeping me sane and i
will say something like thank you very
much that means a lot to me and they'll
say no no you're not getting it you're
keeping me sane right there are people
who are watching us
who are being told
an entirely fictional story
and then to hear i i think it amounts to
this
somebody who is decent and clearly not
trying to mislead them
smart enough to sort through
things
and ready to say out loud what they
think is a very rare phenomenon and so
just even i think the point is
you could probably predict
how likely somebody is to have not
been drawn into the nonsense just based
on the quality of the reality checks in
their life almost nobody who didn't have
a reality so i'm going to pull you up on
this then let's test it yeah so you and
i both remember each other through these
last two years yeah and we exchanged
texts and we were like encouraging and
listen we're here for each other and i
appreciate you came on my show before i
was let go of um when you were doing
your ivor mexican stuff i was keen to
support that
and it was for that reason i got you on
but also retweeting your comments on it
and stuff so we remember those days yeah
but let's go before and after those days
so would you have predicted
before that what happened that i would
have been the one in the uk speaking to
you about this stuff no
right so how does that marry with what
you just said well um
because i know most people wouldn't have
predicted this look first of all there
are some things about you that are
different and i'm a huge believer that
the
the most underrated phenomenon from the
point of view of understanding adults is
childhood right developmental experience
is everything and i don't mean childhood
like you know really young but i mean
what you've been through shapes what you
are capable of seeing what you're
willing to endure yeah and you spoke
about this other way up right yeah
you have been through
um
incredible
hardship and you have been through
incredible hardship and you've come out
the other side and
frankly i think it builds a strength of
character that just doesn't exist in
most of the people that we would hope
would have it and so
what i really think is that
many of the coveted narratives
were covered
in a layer of sophistry that was
supposed to that was supposed to keep
you away and the sophistry wasn't good
enough on its own to do it but the
sophistry couple you're saying
experience gives you a [ __ ] detector
well it in your case i think what it did
is it gave you courage and the point is
most people
actively
um
broke their own understanding they you
couldn't
drag them to the truth because they
instinctively knew that if they saw the
truth it was going to you know
unleash a world of hell for them and so
the point i mean and frankly they want a
psychological you're saying there's a
psychological barrier there i'm saying
that you and i both know that there was
nothing fun
about having whatever it is that was
distributing that awful narrative
target you yeah it was awful and so the
point is okay it was awful but what
choice do i have is something most
people don't say to themselves what they
do is they find reasons not to be saying
the kinds of things that make that
happen and so
i think
um
you know
what you went through
gave you
room that others couldn't find yeah but
but then when you so to pick pick up
further because we got sort of when we
even raised this on the way up before we
sat down this is what i said i said to
you
fine you may have learned the alphabet
first but once i say to you okay look
abcdef and then i'm showing it to you
what's precluding somebody at that stage
learning the alphabet with you is that
the psychological barrier
i really think it's fear
i really think it's yeah yeah and it's
fear that so
it's intellectual
capability and fear how related are they
because i think they're more related
than most people realize
well here's what i've seen
in academia before any of this coveted
stuff happened i was already
you know for obvious reasons
um
quite disappointed with the academy and
basically
i concluded a couple things one
we are in
an epidemic of cowardice right the
amount of cowardice is incredible right
things people used to endure regularly
people are just completely unwilling to
face but the second thing is academia
selects for it
right if you have a mentality where you
know you want to be in the ivory tower
and you don't want to get your hands
dirty right and you like you know
uh jousting in that particular you know
gentlemanly way
then the academy might be where you land
and what that means is that when the
academy falls apart when the academy
forgets how to think right the number of
people who will stand up and say sorry
i'm not going along with that
is tiny right we we saw this at
evergreen which was
five years ago yesterday
evergreen melted down five years ago
yesterday 23rd so rachel told me that on
the way to see you guys in bath and she
was like do remember it's five years
because heather apparently wrote about
it and said she's going offline for a
bit yeah because rachel follows
heather's sub stack i should say for the
record right everybody should follow
yeah
hi heather um but uh but the point is
the
the pattern at evergreen was very clear
right
some people in a crisis
will disappoint you right we saw that a
bunch with people we had called friends
with all of our colleagues with a couple
of exceptions right literally the entire
entire faculty failed the inside
assignment and then we saw people do the
other thing we saw people we didn't know
had incredible courage who stood up and
you know said the truth and it was
really important but the distinction the
fact that the people who surprised us in
the pleasant direction weren't on the
faculty was very conspicuous and i think
it's about a failure the academy
attracts people who are
frankly
risk averse and it makes them a hazard
yeah
yeah and
linking that back to the point about
encouraging narcissism you can imagine
how in an atomized society
uh
fear would increase anxiety
into fear would increase and courage
would decrease because
i look at it this way if you've got
nothing to fight for now loving
relationships so a whole bunch of people
woke up when they said with these
mandates that they were coming for the
kids for example yeah you noticed
parents suddenly thinking what the [ __ ]
and then mother's group started emerging
and the nurses started speaking up
because they've all got kids right so if
you don't have loving relationships so
like i've often posted online you know
and i'm very open by the way and as you
know anything you hear me say publicly
i'll say privately and you know my
uh it's why my sort my show sorry
is is literally on a decentralized
platform encouraging decentralized
funding it's a sub stack and this that's
that's how i want to live i want people
to know where i'm coming from open
source yeah open source yeah
so
how do we get to that what was i saying
um we were talking about the cowardice
in the academy so so i've i so i
was working in a comfy cushy role yeah
on a national mainstream
why am i
prepared to shipwreck that yeah
because i'm reading in the press they're
coming for my five-year-old
now there's nothing worse so i've often
posted that's how i got to it what i
post i'm open right so i often posted
that meme of rambo one first blog with
sylvester stallone and you know what it
says with a text on the meme and it says
um uh uh wait until those who just
wanted to be left alone
right yeah uh
have to come right so
i saw myself as just having a cushy life
and you come for my kid right sorry now
i'm just gonna have to fight every
single one of you at once at the same
time yeah and i don't give a [ __ ] right
because you're saying you're going to
inject my kid against my without my
consent
because it's somehow a
an illness that has been proven as a
matter of parliamentary record in
hansard has an infection infection
fatality rate is 0.096 percent which is
comparable to the flu and you're telling
me you can inject our children at five
years old without our say so
so you what you do there the value of a
loving relationship is it provides that
courage without even needing it right
now if you can atomize society and if
you can make people live in these shoe
boxes back to that whole roger scrutin
philosophy yeah it's really important
because
you're you're concerned about say
courage and i'm saying concerned about
say uh family or say community it's all
the same thing because i believe they're
interrelated
right some of the bravest warriors what
are they fighting for not money
yeah you find you could this concept of
uh the kamikaze right the concept of the
shahid put aside the one that kills
civilians with them because it happens
even without civilian targets because
that's where it's originally come from
it's common in military context just the
concept i'm talking about the raw
concept of it they're never fighting for
money you know unless it's for money
because when they die it's going to go
to their kids who are starving in the
gutter in other words they're not
fighting for money right they're
fighting for love
and and actually radicalization often
begins with that you know the road to
hell is paved with good intentions it's
always a nice emotion it begins with a
concern a love yeah and so i think if
you atomize people you can do two things
you can remove anything worth fighting
for from their lives but also
any emotions they do have it's a lot
easier than to steer those and get to
that point where they held the road to
hell was paid with good intentions
because whatever good intentions they
have left those good intentions exist in
isolation it's so much easier to hijack
an isolated person's good intentions
than it is to hijack somebody who's
embedded
in loving relationships because they
always have other people to think about
so their ideas are harder to hijack
because they don't exist in isolation
they exist for other people to care for
so i can't just come and take you
because anything i say she's going to be
good for you you're going to also
evaluate whether it's good for heather
and for your kids and for your community
you know yeah so um one of my
uh
insights in evolutionary space that i
think
needs to be explored is
lineage yeah so there's a debate in my
field about whether
[Music]
individual selection and kin selection
are the way to think about it or what's
called group selection group selection
is nonsense
the real deal is lineage right and
that's what you're talking about you're
talking about something that you know
you are a temporary uh a temporary
manifestation of something durable and
that is why people will actually uh
willingly die uh
for a cause in general is that that
cause is central to the well-being of
their lineage going forward so that this
is vital stuff which raises an important
question right we can see
a radical failure
um imagine you take away the desire for
that lineage in the first place
chemically chemically
you know right this is what's going on
dude it's not it's all i joined the dots
in this way right so this whole thing
about experimenting with kids with these
puberty blockers
that's exactly where i'm going go for it
go for it sorry man no no no i mean
we see the same picture which is that
across the board there look
a parent
who is told
you know what we've just discovered that
there aren't boys and girls that you
know sexuality is
not binary and that you know you can be
born in the wrong body happens all the
time and when that happens we have no
obligation but to go out no alternative
but to go actually with you know surgery
and pharmaceuticals right the proper
answer to that is go [ __ ] yourself right
that is not a reasonable approach that
is my child you are
let's put it this way let's put it in
the real terms
there is a reason
that we universally
despise child molesters that nothing is
so reliably going to raise in us our
anger as the idea of a child molester
why because a child molester takes
somebody who has done nothing wrong and
maims them psychologically maims them in
a way that they never escape right so
the point is look anybody who's going to
maim your child
you are allowed to have frankly
you were allowed to defend that person
yeah and in the strongest possible terms
right now the fact that the person who
is going to maim your child is a doctor
doesn't much matter the fact that they
have the backing of some academics who
claim to have discovered that sex
doesn't exist
this is the thing is what it's white
look sorry
oh sorry but we can we can this is
important we can just do this and you
can refit me once i've done it here
sorry about it so we'll just keep to let
it roll it's cool man it's natural right
so uh
basically yeah don't panic producer man
let it be natural so
uh i'll fit this back on you know uh in
a second but you know where i'm going
with this because this is important for
people to considering what we've just
come through so
as you can see right
see that right that that scar there
happened to me i was born in britain my
mom my mom is a immigrant from pakistan
and she
from the age of zero to three took me to
pakistan
and at some point somebody put something
in my arm now
i don't know about you yeah
but injection shouldn't look like that
by the age of 44. now till this day i
don't know what that is but i probably
find out
um however it's certainly not something
that isn't given today because i don't
see kids with that kind of scar on their
arms anymore now that was done in
pakistan now you know you will remember
on on rogan i spoke about the fact it is
now an undeniable indisputable fact that
the cia ran fake hepatitis b vaccine
programs in pakistan because they
formally apologize for it so
it's important i say this because
sometimes people imagine you're one of
the most prominent vocal critics of the
mandates yet you're double jab people
need to understand i have people have
been jabbing me all my life without me
knowing what the [ __ ] they've been
putting into me including in jail so
when i was asked to take two jabs for me
it was no big deal because i've i've
already got half i don't know what's in
my body there's another one here
that's the one i don't know what what
was put inside me right in in prison the
dude next door to me and the cell died
of hepatitis b and he was my friend his
name was hisham and he dropped dead in
his cell we all
started writing that night right but i
don't know what was put in me but it was
around the same time so
you mentioned hepatitis b and he died in
it and i know what happened in pakistan
with these fake hepatitis b vaccine now
this kind of behavior is a scar it is
not just a physical scar right so you
talk about maiming children so imagine
you've gone through that and you're an
adult and then somebody says they're
gonna start doing that to your kid over
my dead [ __ ] body right that's it
the point is look a parent is built
right to be a wall to prevent people
from harming that child and the idea
that we are now seeing this failure
across the board right
how many parents have revealed that they
are actually going to tolerate this
nonsense it's incredible it's a total
failure of the understanding of what the
role of parent is and so
you know we see that
with respect to the mandates we see that
with respect to this
sudden shift in our sense about trans
and what it obligates parents to do and
you know of course
i'm not uncompassionate about the fact
there are trans people it's not an easy
way to be and frankly the earlier that
they can access help the better i only
talk about the children right don't
don't don't put these chemicals into
children let them grow up and make their
own minds up they might be gay they
might be lesbian we don't know right let
them grow up first right you know you're
you're i think on the adults debate i
don't disagree with you yeah but my main
concern because they're doing it here at
the tavistock clinic without parental
consent on pre-pubescent kids
you're talking about it's been stopped
now you're talking about the vaccine
mandate no i'm sorry about the time at
the time
because yeah yeah yeah it's uh it's a
total failure of one's obligation as a
parent and um
that indicates something about
the level of coherence of our own
understanding of what we're supposed to
be doing on this planet so yeah
no but i want to bring you back to this
right so
this is obvious what we've just spoken
about should be obvious and yet there
are men and i use that word on purpose
right there are men
who do have kids and have partners who
are living in the same society as us who
are being told the same thing that that
their kids will be injected without
their consent and these men didn't
discover a problem
in that happening yeah and i'm still
trying to work out why if i've taught
you abc i can see why you didn't first
learn abc especially if you're coming
from a different language and abc is a
new language for you and i'll help you
learn it but once i've taught you that
what is it what why because
the the if the most base instinct is
that we can identify this protection of
the lineage what fails in the circuitry
of that person if you hit the thing that
should be the one thing they're alive
for if you strip away strip it down says
bare essentials right and that still
hasn't
shot them what's going on there in your
in your view um i think it is a failure
of
heuristics
so the mind
cannot process everything as it is and
make decisions it's too much right so
what we do is we make
useful simplifications in order to do
the job and in fact you know you can see
this at a neurological level in your
visual system right the
if you were to process
each
you know firing of a receptor in your
eye and try to make sense of how the
room was based on all that individual
data
you'd never be able to process it you
know fast enough to walk down the stairs
so what we do is we have little rules of
thumb built into our visual system that
radically simplify the job of figuring
out where the objects are we perceive
edges for example right edges are very
easy to see because the chromatism
changes so we have all of these
simplifications and most of the time
it works so beautifully but you know
we've all been fascinated by optical
illusions optical illusions are just
things that hover between two
interpretations so that your mind flips
back and forth trying to figure out
which one it is right and so
the point is
if you
if your experience has been look
they're a bunch of vaccines and i take
them
and i don't really know much about their
safety but i'm told they're
safe enough in fact i'm told they're
very safe and what's more i'm told that
i'm much safer having them than not
having them and so far it's been okay
and then somebody says oh my god there's
a terrifying disease and we have one of
these vaccines and you're going to have
to take it and it's really safe and
effective the point is it hits you at
well
you know i've never questioned the
vaccine before and now suddenly i'm
being told i definitely need this one
and it's more important than usual and
what do i know and i think you know what
heather and i were saying was
people
misunderstood because the delivery
mechanism was a syringe
they thought this was a variation on a
theme that they had already made the
call about and so what alarmed heather
in me was we could look at the novelty
of what was in that vaccine do you know
you know but perhaps the preparation
you're making they're talking you're
alluding to when they've already made a
call on on something i think back to the
whole wakefield saga yeah and the mmr so
i remember because my eldest son i have
two boys and the one from the previous
marriage i referenced he's now 21. so
he's the baby back then that we had to
make that decision about mmr and after
much research we did
but we really did pause on that at the
time i was still in islamist right and
so we were we were having all these
debates as islamists and so we didn't
trust the system yeah i really had to
look into it and then made the decision
okay i'll do it but it took us a couple
of months both me and my then wife to
actually say we're going to do that but
then of course i don't need to tell the
rest of story the whole scandal then
that happened and obviously wakefield
got struck off and now
you know um uh others speak in his
defense i i don't want to get into that
debate but i do want to say that
that that debate happening
i almost i think that the way in which
it was concluded in the public
perception
acted as that
uh rehearsal that you've just i think
alluded to i don't know what you think
oh i think this absolutely happened and
i also think that they have overplayed
their hand here because they have
revealed what they are willing to do and
to lie about and it now has many people
i mean look i've my kids are
fully vaccinated up until the point that
we're talking about covet right we
vaccinated them with everything now
look i was a biologist then too and as
is heather and our decision was very
very clear right
it makes sense to delay these things as
long as possible why
because if they're going to harm you
the amount of harm they will do will be
reduced the more of your development has
already been completed normally right so
we delayed every vaccine to the
reasonable point that you could delay it
right that so what that's about
did i make the right decision i mean not
that you're a i mean i should be asking
it then don't watch this but but in your
opinion not the right we don't give
medical advice right would you repeat
what i said what i just said would you
do that here's here's where i am now and
this is this is what's going to get us
in trouble okay
now
having seen what they did over kovid
having learned what i have about
vaccines i now do not trust the system
that produces it yeah this is where you
and i agree right i am still an
enthusiast about vaccination but i am
livid that we don't have a system that
can be trusted to produce them and that
i can look at and say that's safe enough
not so much on that one can i reference
where this came up in the conference we
were just at so for some of your
audience who may not know but you
introduced it anyway we were just at the
world health council conference in bath
uk which is why you're in my beautiful
city london welcome we're in the east
end and uh i hope you have had a great
time in this city
i know you've been busy as well which uh
your audience is going to love but um
we were there and a debate ensued um i
don't think i want to mention names i
don't know because was it filmed if it
filmed like mention names right it was
physical
okay yeah so about it big tree was there
and um
and bosch were there yeah and a debate
ensued between those two in the session
the you know opening session that i was
chairing and you were present
and
in essence to summarize it and i believe
this is when you raised the point and i
had a chat with rachel my missus and
said i agreed with your point and this
was the point that
dell was saying like you know
the data that the fda the cdc which
everyone is referencing haven't released
the data that is urgently needed on this
stuff the vaccines before
they start rolling them out
and if that data is released and it
becomes transparent that they cause more
harm than good if that data shows that
and it's a it's an if we have to put the
if underlined there yeah and what he
referenced was for example autism
combined with uh allergies now one thing
that this dutch does touch a raw nerve
with me is i'm 44 years old i remember
as a child never having there was no
such thing as people dying from eating
peanuts yeah right so i don't know don't
unless i'm like something's wrong with
my memory but people try and gaslight me
on this stuff but i do not recall people
dying from eating peanuts now the
problem part of the problem is as all
reference in 1984 who knows what the
truth is anymore right but but i you
know i don't remember that being a
problem until suddenly it was a problem
we can certainly say that the problem of
serious food allergies has grown and has
not been satisfactorily explained yeah
it could be gm crops i'm not saying
what's causing i'm saying dell's point
was combine all of that data together so
you get where i'm going with this yeah
and he's saying if
that data aggregated demonstrates that
these things are causing more harm
vaccines are causing more harm than good
he said to gert would you then as a
vaccinologist accept the fact that these
shouldn't be rolled out gert's response
was
you know you're not always talking about
basically i'm a vaccinologist and that's
not how it works right now i don't want
to get into his technical garden because
what interested me was your point and
and you you then piped up and you said
guys guys guys you're not getting it
this date is not going to be released
because in this i remember is what you
said the quote right you said because
every single one of our institutions has
been corrupted and this is to your
systemic
uh floor point that's what i believe
that's where we are so that even if it
was doing good if it's coming from
voices that you no longer trust
you can't recognize good if you don't
trust the person speaking to you about
it right full stop
you know this is true and i will say um
from the beginning my sense with the
entire
covid fiasco
was that it reveals
just how rotten our system has become
and so while i thought it was very
important to talk about all of the
issues around covid and while i was well
positioned to do that as a biologist who
was capable of you know learning the
relevant vaccine information the
epidemiological information and could
use my toolkit as an evolutionist
the key thing that i thought was
important was once you understand what
happened over the lab leak once you
understand what happened over repurposed
drugs and early treatment and once you
understand what happened with the claim
that the coveted vaccines were safe and
effective
you can see i'm going to add care homes
and and and and
remittance veer graham disappeared
you can add that to the list you could
also you could also add the that's my
next episode by the way in this show
midazolam oh you want to watch it it's
dude
shocking
please watch it yeah believe me you sent
me that link for episode
455. this is six so i'll send it to you
but
just and by the way it's the tip of the
iceberg
yeah well that's the thing is this is a
hell of an iceberg so i would also add
uh escape variants to the list but
anyway even just the three right
lab leak yeah early treatment vaccine
safe and safety and effectiveness
once you understand how wrong what you
were told was on all three of those
fronts then you know something what you
know is
you know university science has failed
you know the public health apparatus has
failed you know that journalism has
failed right politics has failed right
and so
once you know that it's actually very
terrifying right what how much danger
would we be in if we didn't have any of
those things looking out for us well
that's how much danger we're in right
this is where you know i added to the
conversation and said we're at war bret
ideological war i don't mean i'm gonna
go shoot people i mean this is an
ideological war on the minds of our
population using all of the institutions
of society and if we've got to recognize
that first and foremost because it's not
about data
if the system's failed
the right data in the wrong hands is
still a problem
because they can weaponize correct
information happens all the time yeah
i'll give you an example the invasion of
iraq is wrong now i'm talking about
propaganda warfare yeah the invasion of
iraq is wrong but guess who believes
that green activists believe that
socialists believe that jihadists
believe that isis believes that al qaeda
believes that right the correct stance
can be weaponized to kill civilians just
as easy as it can to have sit in
protests so when you talk about
propaganda warfare part of the problem
is the conversation they're having about
provide the data it's why i said and i
sat on that table and i said we're at
war i wasn't actually making dell's
point i was making my own point even
though i sounded like i'm agreeing with
dell
because he was saying it but
what he was alluding to i was saying it
but my point is that if you recognize
that then even having
making sure that through public
accountability transparency the correct
institutions are forced to acknowledge
the correct data like pfizer did has
that changed anything with the problem
that we're in just the fact that the
judge always advises data to be
released you know i mean it's
incremental change but the but the if if
you want to weaponize correct
information you can now what we've
really got to start addressing is the
failure of these institutions and that
touches on the failure of our collective
consciousness to be able to imagine a
future beyond technocracy
i agree i do want to come this is a
death star moment problem here this is a
death star moment it's also
as much as i know
that anybody who invokes it is going to
be accused of
alarmism or something it's also a storm
the cockpit moment right i really
believe that and i'm happy to defend
that belief it's i'm not it's not
hyperbole but we i mean china is an
example of how i mean this is i don't i
mean hyperbole we've gone beyond that
brett look you see all the videos in
with the lockdown in china right you saw
yeah now now the data there's been a
hack today and more data data's come out
about the week our concentration camps
anyone that now says this is hyperbole
try it with me i'll accuse you of
defending genocide yeah basically well
it makes sense to me in order to you're
going to come back with something yeah i
want to come back to what happened at
this conference because there are a
couple of features you know people
people are going to weaponize this
against us even just discussing the
possibility that this is not a clear-cut
issue is is uh
heresy
so
on the panel which you were hosting um
garrett vandenbosch was on it i was on
it and robert malone was on it along
with a number of other people
and the three of us so that's two
vaccinologists and an evolutionary
biologist were
pushing back on where dell was trying to
take us and dell's point was if the net
effect of these vaccines is negative
will you agree they shouldn't be used
garrett vandenbosch's point i think was
too subtle for people to understand it
and it is crucial to be in this
discussion his point was
we have a mechanism let's take the
measles vaccine
if the measles vaccine is creating
immunity then what we have is a
population with a large number of people
who have been immunized we're above
heard immunity and that's why we don't
have lots of measles now the problem is
new people are constantly being born and
that
increases the number of people who have
not been vaccinated now what we do is we
have a vaccine schedule and we vaccinate
them
and according to dell
they shouldn't be vaccinated and
according to garrett well if you don't
vaccinate them what what even is
eventually you will get to the point
that there are enough
immuno naive people that you will get an
outbreak and his point is look dell
you
are taking on the responsibility or
maybe you're failing to take on the
responsibility of all of the people who
might die in that circumstance yes point
was you can't put a number on that
figure because it's exponential as the
generation grows and so you can't even
possibly begin to work the comparison
out because dale's like what if we had
the data i don't think so it's like you
can't compare them because you don't
know how many people are going to be
suffering in the future the problem is
there are certain things we can measure
right we should be measuring all cause
mortality and we should say what is the
net effect of this vaccine but garrett's
point which i think is excellent is
you can't know the net effect because
all cause mortality doesn't capture the
benefit of all of the people who didn't
get the disease because you're about
qualified you can't well you can
estimate it there are things you can do
but you can't that's what he said you
could do that but then you're going to
accuse it being a modelling and no one
likes the modeling right yeah yeah it's
it's it's an it's a very good point by
the way it's a very good point i wasn't
the reason i didn't summarize it is
because i was your point is what
actually i think deals with it anyway
without having to get into the science
right which is that we're in we're in an
information environment where we're not
going to be able to know even if it has
the data we don't know what it means
because there's too much corruption no
but also that yeah too much corruption
means that even the correct data will
not be utilized i mean look at your
arrival acting thing the data is there
now right look at lockdowns the data is
out there but they are deliberately not
allowing the public
to become aware of the fact that these
things fail even though the data is
there for the public to see who goes and
looks up the science behind lockdowns
what we need is the front pages that
won't happen and so if the institutions
aren't for the people
it doesn't matter if uh
dell gets his data
right and yes exactly
and that's why i mean why we're at
ideological war well so they're not
playing by the rules no they're not
playing by the rules and they are also
um
they have put us in grave danger because
it is not like the people who are
structuring the narrative and denying us
access to information are good at
managing things right they're obviously
terrible at it and
what so the point is nobody is looking
out for us right they are as deluded as
we are confused and it leaves us in
terrible jeopardy there's a problem
though when this happens brett
because the more you keep a lid on
something
it's a pressure cooker moment right now
you and i are having this lovely gentle
conversation but there are people out
there that aren't as genteel noticing
things that we're noticing just because
they're not
living on the system by definition
they're the underworld right
and in moments like this if you keep
trying to keep a lid on the truth
things blow over because at the same
time you're expecting people to behave
the same way bring me your child so i
can jab them yeah everyone knows it's
not good and you're still telling
everyone it is and your front page is
onyx but that incrementally grows to a
point where if the democratic
institutions are no longer serving the
people what do people do there's going
to be riots with the food shortages
well what they're doing
is they are
creating
look if you don't have somewhere to go
to sort out what makes sense what's the
best we can given that the official
sources are clearly not informing us
yeah
what can we piece together if you don't
know where to go or who to trust to
start piecing things together then your
only line of defense is some kind of
radical cynicism where you just don't
trust anything right because if if it's
a garbage environment where you know the
noise is is out competing the signal and
then what happens what grows in that
environment right what grows in that
environment
i've been trying to raise the alarm i
mean who else other than me to talk
about the dangers of rising extremism
yeah the problem is again you've got a
scenario here where now i i'm a
the way in which people are shutting
down something it's like uh robert
malone knows mrna technology because he
[ __ ] invented it and holds the one of
the inventors of it and holds the
patents on it right so if i i'm speaking
to robert malone about mrna technology
and he says something and then oh you
don't know what you're talking about
which is what that muppet invites news
basically wrote yeah yeah right and it's
like hold on a minute so back to the
thing you'll talk about evolutionary
biology and i who've never gone beyond
gcse's in biology right sit there now
brett man you know what you're talking
about you know what what is wrong with
people so we're talking about scenario
i'm talking now here back to that point
where it's like if you can recognize
what's going on right this is this is
the moment we're in right and there are
people raising the alarm so why i'm
saying all this extremism is i know it
inside out okay it's why [ __ ] prime
ministers called upon me to speak to
them about it right tony blair david
cameron president bush
sat there like this talking to them
about extremism and look that's not
because i was born into the right family
and because i have wealth right they
were obviously not calling me because
i'm their uncle's cousin's niece right
they're asking upon me because i had
something to say on the topic i still
have something to say in the topic it's
a problem it's going to rise because of
this that you've just identified they're
not listening
right
if they're not going to listen to robert
malone on vaccine technology they're not
going to listen to me on my analysis of
the dangers of rising extremism what is
going on well
that's it i keep you know every time i
stumble onto the same
set of things from some new angle it's
the
what the [ __ ] is going on moment right
it's like how crazy would you have to be
to to run these risks now now now add to
that right so
this is what
when i say we're at war but this is what
i mean so the only thing that makes
sense is in a war you do not listen to
your
good people that understand what they're
talking about because everything is
weaponized
well they have specifically
and viciously marginalized
all of the people who are trying to
for the common good
which is a war excuse i mean look
let's be honest we don't know why they
did it they could be um insane and
arrogant at a level that is hard to
imagine or they could be up to something
we don't understand we don't know jack
pasobi just went to wef davos right i
think he sees twitter as his twitter
account jack pasobic he's the former u.s
navy in celebs and and wef has a police
force obviously their local police with
patches but they have a wef patch on
them they just arrested jack for filming
so the devil if summit is happening and
they've got their own global police
force in the form of co-opted local
police serving as wef police arresting
journalists
now are you do you take the view i do
that this is going to get a lot worse
before we start seeing anything start
getting better
it is likely to get a lot worse i will
say and i
among the things i probably shouldn't
say into a camera is this
i think we
shocked them
over the course of this covet madness
now i don't know about you you know
you're sitting here now independent you
had a job with a very large audience and
you know
basically everything taken care of
except you delivering the content
and i will say
um
this change
uh your set is a marvelous upgrade
your last set was
not your last set was a crime against
humanity
but this is not this so uh my producer
hayden and it's her work man so yeah
well this is this is much lovelier much
easier on the eyes and all but um
nonetheless
the
those of us
who
[Music]
did the job who actually chased this
stuff down and talked about what it was
i believe we had a very big impact on
how many people were fooled and it
doesn't mean that most people weren't
but the number of people so they didn't
see as common is it i i well here's
here's my model
we are up against something i just for
shorthand call it goliath okay i'll call
it the death star the death star all
right well goliath
is
going to be some fraction
conspiracy and if you think it's not a
conspiracy then you don't understand
that you know a board room that is
trying to make a profit on
pharmaceuticals has a fiduciary
obligation to conspire on the behalf of
its of itself you don't understand that
sinister palpatine was really emperor
about it
so um anyway so there's some fraction of
you know
i guess maybe if i say collusion that
means it's inherently illegal but
whatever people
conspire on their own behalf and then
there's some fraction of it which is an
emergent property right it's an emergent
property of the system and the way
information flows here's the reason that
that's important we don't know what the
admixture is it could be mostly emergent
it could be mostly conspiratorial we
can't tell but
the part that's emergent
is
effectively an adaptation right it's
evolved and here's what's important
about that
an evolved entity
is not good at fighting things that it's
never fought before right and that means
that
that is a where you should always doing
a warfare succeeds right so this isn't
this thing is very powerful but
it is inept at fighting things it
doesn't understand you know what it
doesn't understand
doesn't understand joe rogan right maybe
it does now but the point is
a massive number of people having a
conversation that isn't on television
that you know can go on an hour two
hours three hours at a time that
involves people who have you know
escaped academia and are capable of
speaking directly to the underlying
biology people who have escaped
extremism and can speak to the
psychological dynamics in play they
weren't counting on a high quality
conversation to break out anywhere and
to reach lots of people who were trying
to figure out for themselves what the
hell was going on right so i do think
um the cost was incredibly high right
you you got bounced out of your secure
position heather and i certainly got
bounced out of ours
and you know even worse than that worse
than you know losing half our income to
youtube's arbitrary censorship garbage
was the slander that has been directed
us and has directed us still right my
wikipedia page is a monstrosity and you
know it means that you know youtube got
in the way of our ability to earn and
then our ability to earn outside of
youtube is compromised by the fact that
people who might want to advertise on
our channel are going to go there and
they're going to think what the hell is
this
so
anyway they made a lot of
it was not a battle that did not inflict
a lot of damage on us but i believe that
our successes are something that we
should um note because we're gonna have
to learn for the next round so they
didn't see us coming i agree 100 with
that now we are seen
yep
so
when i said guerilla warfare is why it
works i said
well it's an irritant because it works
up until a point
right
until until the
the attack walkers come along right and
then you're like on this little jedi
bike and the attack will att walkers are
coming with their four legs and their
laser beams and they're shooting at you
from above so we've got a problem here
because you know we are still
as good as we just did we are still
massively outmanned oh well
this is this is why i'm distressed
because
um we did not
cross the threshold we needed to get
over the threshold was agreement on
lab leak early treatment vaccine safety
and effectiveness once we get those then
the point is there's an obvious
conversation that has to happen yeah how
did that occur right and we didn't get
there let's see what we are we're rocky
one we still gotta be apollo in rocky
two all right yeah um wow all right
that's really helpful because i recall
it's been a long time really work out
yeah because it's good until they start
making rocky six seven eight nine they
just get silly yeah but one and two were
great films and it's a great film anyway
but um i think
i give these film analogies because not
everybody
people sometimes think serious topics
it's it's good to keep it like you know
light for people to understand as well
and i think that that gives hope because
yeah there's a
we are out man there's a huge huge
problem out there which is far bigger
than you can take and i can take on our
own or even combined right we have found
each other that's another good point
though right as in not we already knew
each other but within who we knew we
then found each other within
within a group of people that was
already pretty damn good right yeah so
so that's an advantage because because
again back to the relational thing
there's nothing more powerful
than a relationship that is based on an
ideal as opposed to material value that
can expire
you know i think that's true i think we
need to learn some of the lessons you
know
you mentioned a point about
collaboration or memory confederation
confederation yeah talk about that a bit
well i mean i think we are about all of
the people who
do have good instincts about seeing
through the nonsense all have a
the same fatal flaw really which is
that they
tend to be
more lone wolf right the way you end up
with enough independence of mind to spot
the nonsense is something that causes
you to be a little less um
you know
team
oriented team oriented
and the problem is that we need to
make teams that work and so we don't
have that skill set in uh in high enough
uh concentration so
that's an issue that we don't have to
address this combination by the way
because uh but by definition what you
just said right
well self-selecting right but
you know i do think actually
and this goes in a very different
direction but
there's sort of an ongoing conversation
about uh important
what i would call myths right these are
stories that resonate sometimes over
thousands of years that are really
important but i think it is also
interesting to watch the ways in which
they change right so
my little toolkit says you can't write a
myth you can write a story and if it is
sufficiently important and useful it
will evolve into a myth it will be
changed over time and it will be altered
until it is distilled down to something
really resonant right
and what i wanted to point to is that
our myths are evolving right there is a
sort of hero's journey right but there
are also lots of versions of the heroes
journey that do involve weird
superheroes that come together with
different skill sets and then part ways
again well they're never fully the same
and they are you know so it is
you know asymmetrical
partnerships and all of this
so that's interesting we can also look
at you know the matrix
is obviously
not the first update of plato's cave but
it's the same basic idea and you know it
has
another dynamic too right it's you know
plato's cave does not end well right um
the matrix is a different story and i'm
going to pretend that there are no
sequels i haven't even seen them because
i know they're no good but um but the
matrix apparently
the one that was just made i haven't
even seen that one but i have seen the
other sequels in yes just watch number
one yeah but
apparently this one that was just made
um it was made
by the people that didn't like the fact
that the matrix became a red pill
reference so they came they in the
studio insisted that the original
writers come back and the original
writers didn't want to do it
um they're trans twins right i think
yeah they didn't want to do it this is a
story around this right and they didn't
want to do it and then the studio said
well we're going to make it with or
without you so you come back and write
this so then they would say they were
quite
came back voluntarily but it was going
to be done if they didn't so they had to
come back so i think what you're telling
me is that
the agents got control of the studio and
the reason that the initial sequels
weren't any good was that those were
written in order to defend the whatever
it is that makes the matrix
right yeah okay that makes sense
um but okay so you know look the story
is all by the way so you just touched on
something i don't know if you realized
it but this remake this one they just it
is all about that going into that story
and then like he's like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like you
know like um adaptation yeah yeah yeah
it's like that kind of and also nick
cage's recent one um the beautiful
what was it called nick cave's
nick cage's recent film um
the the wonderful burden of fame or
something you'll see is it's a title
like that which is riffing off a
beautiful mind um the previous film so
um it's a similar adaptation story plot
and so i think the latest matrix has
done the same thing and so
i think they think it's intelligent
filmmaking if they do that
they're right yes
because i haven't seen it i'm not going
to give a judgment on it yeah yeah no
let's not review it if we haven't seen
it that would be that would be somehow
right
um
but you know look
we have discovered that we are in
something matrix-like right the
information environment is so polluted
that
we have to figure out you know how to
shut down the matrix and
see the world for what it is and
you know and grapple with the terror
that comes from recognizing just
how
captured the system has become
um but we also do have stories that
you know that
properly
if you look at them right that warn us
and we also have old stories you know we
have they are so important these stories
right
and we have orwell and you know and not
just orwell we have you know we have
brave new world we have catch-22 we have
uh brazil
lots of these things have something to
tell us and there are lots of people who
are now
awake
don't know what to do but the real
question is can we
level up faster than the other thing
that the thing that we're up against
levels up against so let's drill down on
this on an ideological perspective yeah
so
uh
so so our
if you look at if you look at our
existence and society so so so we are
outlived as you correctly pointed out by
myths that survive not just us but
through lineage survived generations and
so the myths are bigger than us
and they serve
us by giving us a sense of anchorage or
perspective in our position vis-a-vis
myths and that is a large part of who we
are right you can't divorce us from
those myths even if you try and rebel
against them like look at the neo
anti-theist movement right you're trying
to rebel against something in an
anti-theist way which i don't subscribe
to in an anti-theist way that is still
defining yourself against the very myth
that brought you to this point you can't
divorce yourself from those myths no
matter how much you try because we are
all a product of these
um sort of overarching narratives that
create the very you know a corporation
is an entity even though sort of
physical thing because it's a fiction
that everyone agrees on like money yeah
these are fictions that everyone agree
on and so
um
uh culture defining myths are like those
they are things that everybody's agreed
on but have been passed on through
generations so like corporations have
their own life
so important what they lead to
those myths is to constructing the
fundamental social contracts that we
find ourselves in over time with a
delayed reaction that's how they
manifest so so we only have law because
of the religious myths that we adopted
in the abrahamic faiths right and you
know don't let me tell you that so
so if that
if that holds right then we need to
discover and this is beyond what jordan
talks about right we need to discover
which i mean i suppose it he talks a lot
about this but also i mean beyond it in
a political sense not just in a
philosophical sense that i think he
addresses it we need to discover which
myths
are valuable to the
problem we're in right now right and
those myths i think need to be
recognized as part of the antidote to
this problem and the stronger uh the
lessons or the moral
um
sort of teachings that those myths are
are portraying the stronger those
lessons become in us as a collective the
more likely it is that whatever comes
next will be a reflection
of that as opposed to what we're worried
about but it has to come down
again to our collective response in a
long-term
context this isn't going to be fixed by
you and me
even with what we have
left in our lives doing the best we can
we're not going to
end this problem we're only going to
make a small dent in in a in a direction
that will that will be a battle between
two opposing directions that will
continue way after we're dead
well i think there is truth in that i do
think we have a short-term problem that
we have to solve the system is so out of
control and the things the power of the
technologies under its management are so
great
that effectively
we have to figure out how to get it to
behave rationally
very short term i don't think we can
solve this over the course of
generations though there are parts yes
so this will be a tweak yeah on this
current problem we have but this problem
as you
look back to history has occurred many
times
yep um
yes we have to fix the one we're in we
have to fix the one we're in and like
never before because we've never been a
threat to ourselves in this way before
that's a new that's a new problem i will
say that um one of my
it's a gentle disagreement that i have
with jordan or maybe it's just a
slightly different emphasis
is that jordan
sees the timelessness
of these myths and i don't doubt that
there's something that is timeless ish
in some of these myths but what i think
he misses
is that
because the myths are products of
evolution they too are limited to the
context that formed them right and some
of them
are no longer
they may have been timeless for a long
period of time if that's a reasonable
way to say it is adaptation
well they are but the point is
you have to beware if your myth was
evolved in an environment that was very
different than the one you're in there's
nothing that says it will be relevant to
the one you're in it could even be the
inverse of relevant it could steer you
in the wrong direction and so
we have to have a mechanism for at least
being aware when our myths have
left us without the right tools like for
example
i used to say that you know if if god
was writing today
then um
the first commandment would be thou
shalt not enrich uranium yeah right but
it's not in there he didn't mention
uranium so we don't know what to do
about we don't know how to feel about it
and um
you know look we're damned if we do and
damned if we don't there's history
there's traditions that got us to where
we are right they're not
up to date enough to get us through what
we've got coming and that leaves us to
trying to navigate it consciously and
it's it's too difficult it also does
something else
this is a i don't even know if i want to
say it because it's so scary because i
agree with everything you just said by
the way and as you know my work on my
side of my communities myths
reflects the fact that i believe certain
things need to be adapted to the
situation we find ourselves in today and
that was everything i was doing up until
covid
we're in a very scary position
intellectually because
if what you just said stands and i think
it does
old myths are not going to address the
acuteness of the very specific problem
we're facing right now which is also
terminal potentially yeah
so it's an acute and potentially
terminal problem that needs an immediate
fix not some long-term jet
multi-generational myth conversation is
we've got to fix this right now
and those long-term multi-generational
myths though they exist
even if we were to be able to draw upon
them aren't
weren't constructed
or weren't a product of this specific
problem they're facing they were
products of a lesser problem that was
similar
yeah but this is a big bad monster it's
why i call it a death star moment yeah
right we've got the so the scary
situation is this finish this thought
considering how big this problem we have
to create
or adapt a new myth today to deal with
this
building perhaps on everything in the
past
that's the scary part
that's the skill who's gonna do that
well right and i'm afraid that we may
also be in an another
bind here so if you take my premise that
you can't write a myth you can write a
narrative and then evolution will shape
it into a myth
uh if it's good
take the fellowship of the ring okay the
fellowship of the ring is a good hero's
journey story that's been updated for
the sort of team mentality that one
would need on a world that's been scaled
up right the villains are scaled up the
um
the the heroes are scaled up
the problem is
effectively it's digitally rendered
right it's printed every copy is
identical and so the substance on which
evolution should act isn't really there
what's worse for something like star
wars or the matrix or any one of the
others
those things are
[Music]
compromised because
i may think the matrix is right on
target with respect to much of its
message
yeah film one
takes plato's cave and makes it
vibrant and updates it for
modern
uh sensibilities and for the modern
predicament but
it's not art
it's a hybrid between art the artistic
vision of the wachowskis i guess
and
the market and what it demands and the
problem is
by two and three it certainly did win in
the end although we can just purge those
sequels and say well the first film was
pretty damn good but the problem is
i don't really trust the market to tell
me anything about wisdom
that's not what the market does right
right and so the point is if my wisdom
that i want to hand off to my kids is
like hey let's watch the matrix
experience
because it's not a popular position
we're in right so the point is look we
have plugged our
myth creation apparatus into the market
wow that was dumb there are a lot of
things you just you don't want to plug
sex and romance into the market you
don't want to plug your your that's very
difficult and myth generation what i'm
referencing is these myths that have
come over generations yeah there's some
good there
what the scary part is i'm saying is the
task has befallen our generation not you
and me because that who who are we right
gen x
and so gen x up because
beyond gen x people don't so gen maybe
what's up after x gen x sorry is it
the millennials
the older side of millennials still do
remember the days before mobile phones
just about
but you need that why do you need that
because you can't understand how to
defeat what we're facing if you don't
remember what it was like before the
thing existed because our task is to
find an equilibrium you can't get the
yin and yang if you don't have half of
the story yeah you've been tweeting
about this yeah i i saw you uh bmx yeah
you've treated your your your bms this
is not a boomer analysis this is
something else right now i would point
out you know it's it's fun to rag on the
boomers i i like it that's not what i'm
interested in right right because it
might be a boomer though
oh my god
what are you saying there's the feds
i'm trying to be
do you agree that you need that sense of
pre uh mobile phones pre-internet to
know how to find equilibrium you need a
lot of these things yeah the fact you
know your point about the bmx your first
tweet that i saw at least was about
the
relationship to the world that those
things gave us right we disappeared for
hour upon hour our parents didn't know
where we were we weren't at home we were
off doing things some of the things we
were doing we shouldn't have done
sometimes we got hurt right but the
point is it created an entirely
different mentality and
kids don't have it if you're
especially if the vibrant part of your
world is coming through screens right
you've been hobbled because you know the
fact is it doesn't have a normal physics
to it so
this is this is so here's the scary part
yeah so
where i was going with that i'm glad you
followed that actually because this is
actually this is the point that builds
on it
it so it becomes the duty of everybody
that remembers the world before mobile
phones and i mean in their consciousness
not just oh i was three years old and my
dad told me there was no [ __ ]
nah man you you gonna be the guy that
had to use the pay phone right and
didn't have the change let's go into the
shop and ask for a note to be broken up
because you had to call somebody or
reverse collect calls you got to be the
guy that remembers what it was like
before mobile phones in the internet
right
that's a certain age group let's call
them 14 above for argument's sake sorry
forgive me for the arbitrariness if
you're 39 and a half and you remember
those days you're included right
that peop that group of people whoever
they are whichever arbitrary age is the
kind cutoff point
it's the burden is on that group of
people and let's say arbitrarily gen x
upwards and element annuals upwards the
burden is on that group of people to
synthesize not these marketed myths to
sympathize the actual myths that come
through general that are
multi-generational because they have
wisdom in them and they're not driven by
the market many of them were
word-of-mouth through lineage right and
that's in particular that's how for
example i know about a sufi chains in
sufism and you have to have a teacher
who has a teacher who has a teacher and
it has to be traced back right right so
so we
those who remember before and after the
internet have a responsibility to find
the best of these proper wise myths and
adapt them to the problem the acute
problem that you identify that is unique
and is terminal potentially that's the
scary part because not only is that such
a huge burden it's also almost
impossible to do because myths actually
as you say are they they are
a product of of evolution over years
right
and and so how do you do that well
luckily for us we're not starting we're
not reinventing then we've got some
existing material the danger the
difficulty is the adaptation of that
existing material to face this very
acute danger we're facing but you can't
do it without myths because you're not
powerful enough and i'm not powerful
enough that entire generation isn't
powerful enough that we're going to need
to do that task right but they can't
even do it unless they utilize these
myths because we're all bigger even the
current
everyone alive today is still not as big
as these myths are they will be
multi-generational all right so i've
just realized something yeah um is that
scary it's terrifying yeah
um
here is the
equally terrifying extension to it i
think
let's step back to what happened
during covet yeah
one of the things that happened that was
very conspicuous was the relationship
between doctors and patients and doctors
and other doctors
suddenly radically shifted there was a
distant voice that told you
what the conclusion was and what it
implied about how to treat your patients
and then it came at you and it ruined
you if you didn't listen yeah so the
point is doctors have a horizontal
relationship with each other and they
have a relationship with their patients
and that whole thing bubbles along and
it does whatever it does until something
decides that you know what suddenly the
cdc is everybody's boss
right and to the extent that you weren't
listening to the cdc
it whispered in the ear of your
pharmacist and said don't fill those
prescriptions don't fill them all right
so that's
a radical shift to a centralization you
don't realize that because the staffing
of your medical building didn't change
there was a radical shift which was the
way in which
um
a tiny incorrect
centralizing force was distributing the
same wrong information to everybody
simultaneously and insisting that they
listen to it and act on it as if it was
right okay now think about social media
we feel like we have all of these
horizontal relationships with other
people right
and we do
but there's a ghost in the machine yeah
right we don't know what the algorithms
are we don't know when they change we
don't know what they want we don't know
how actively we can be individually
targeted we don't know any of the things
we would like to know and so
what i see is
the impression that we have about yeah
we're connected with lots and lots of
people and we're interacting and we're
you know it's like a high of mind
no it's not a hive mind it's something
very susceptible to imagine that
hypnosis came from within and not from
outside like you can note the guy
outside who's trying to hypnotize you
with the watch but if that guy comes in
you know through the brain stem
you're not going to spot it
and so
i mean part of the
whatever you want to call it i would say
the clear collective psychosis that has
accompanied the phenomena of the last
couple of years
is partially downstream of this
yeah and this brings me to
without being rude about anyone but a
conversation about our friends okay
because what was meant to happen
in the good old days before the world
went [ __ ] right
it's always been bad for a while for me
at least but still you know you know
what i'm referring to in the last two
years here what should happen is there
was a group of people
that should have been like a team
100 yeah and should have mobilized the
world right 100 out of those group
people that i'm thinking of you can
count on one hand the number of people
that did actually start doing anything
right and at the very least
the ones who didn't
should have said i don't understand why
people that i know full well are careful
and well intentioned have reached a
conclusion i can't understand that is
not a reason to demonize them that is a
reason to become very interested
somebody has to be wrong who is it let's
figure it out and out of all the people
you've been speaking to here in um
london while you've been here for dark
horse yeah um by the way congratulations
man great podcast yeah because it's
important to say that because i uh um
robert malone said to me he was like i
went on dark horse and that's how i
ended up on rogan you've been a
springboard for many people and without
that platform people like malone's voice
wouldn't have been heard so it has to be
acknowledged on this platform yeah now
sorry the reason i mention this is
that
that thing that should have happened the
group of friends we have now out of all
the people you've interviewed while
you're here
um if i can be so bold as to say that
you and i share a group of friends more
so than the other people you're speaking
to including the people you've recently
met because you and i were friends
before this covet stuff happened and
we're speaking about other stuff that we
felt was as important that we were
addressing then right without recapping
history so so so we've got a shared
group of friends and it might be why you
know this is such a relaxed and lovely
enjoyable conversation yeah well i've
dined with you and your wife you know
you've met my wife and now
and my wife is as i say follows my sub
stack and your wife's sub stack right
and that's pretty much the only sub
substance she reads because she's in a
different world she's an artist a
musician and so on so so we've got this
group of friends that we're close to
that i love still yeah and that's why i
don't want to name names and i'm not
bitching on anyone here yeah because i
love them still and i've in fact made a
point because i knew by the way i don't
you don't know this they know this the
people like you all know i did this
right the minute covid started i started
texting my friends i love you it's been
nice i'm going on a bit of a journey you
might not and i hinted you know i'm not
going to paraphrase what i said with
different people you might not
understand what's about to happen
because i knew this would happen i've
lived this all my life with people not
knowing why i've taken the stances of
taking including my ex family on the
extremism debate i know what happens
when you do this which is why perhaps i
saw it coming a lot faster so i message
those people that i'm referencing as our
common friends i love you randomly
without solicitation so they know
no matter what happens even if they
don't agree with me i'm not going to
take it personally just
don't also do the same and start
attacking me i'm your friend
now the reason i'm mentioning all this
is we've got to a point where i believe
there's been a failure of people that
have a responsibility back to the burden
i just mentioned right there's only a
certain group of people that can bear
that burden for the entire generation
that needs to move collectively to take
our traditional myths into the next
phase beyond this death star moment
right
the responsibility to help gen x upwards
with the elder millennials included
carry that burden lies on a certain
group of people that had posited
themselves up until this moment as being
ready for that burden right including
the fanfare in the [ __ ] media
articles they had posited themselves as
being ready for that moment and there
was something akin to a
system failure
that happened in that group of friends
to a point where you can now count on
on on one hand with fingers spare who
actually address the covid stuff
and i'm not it's not a personal thing
for me it's a disappointing thing for me
that because it's the kind of moment
where
at the moment we needed it the most it
needed to have happened
there is no more important moment than
this death star right this is this has
been
and i'm going to say something and i'm
going to repeat this i love you all
these friends know who i'm talking about
you miss the [ __ ] boat
and they might think i'm stupid nah man
they missed the boat you didn't
no i didn't they missed the vote and i'm
not being i don't mean to be dismissive
of anything they missed there is a
moment here they have missed that they
have not begun to fathom and i don't
mean to be patronizing
all right here's a small [ __ ] plan i
think we have to figure out what the
best way forward is and i'm going to i'm
going to say something yeah
so first of all they did miss the boat
but it's not completely gone yet for the
following reason yeah fine give a rope
but jump on board man here's where i
think we are
lab leak yeah come on yeah we all know
what happened yeah right this is clearly
a
modified virus this this is clearly a
self-inflicted wound yeah
inflicted on humanity vaccine safety and
effectiveness
reasonable people can disagree over the
net impact of these injections but the
idea that they were ever understood to
be safe and effective is obviously
preposterous you don't even need that
brit you know what for the people i'm
talking about admit it was mandated your
alarm bell should have stopped yeah but
still okay they told us they were safe
and effective we all know about
myocarditis right we all know that they
did not properly risk stratify by age or
any of those things they put people at
risk were they safe no
were they safe enough we can argue but
were they safe no if you ever said they
were safe you were wrong were they
effective well look at how many boosters
you're being told they got these are
very very weak vaccines not safe not
effective have not controlled the
pandemic so
that's two out of three right we were
right on two out of three
now the sticky wicket is ivermectin and
we can argue about why that is that was
your main one of your main points wasn't
it well and lots of people have the
sense right what what people say about
me on twitter or maybe they're maybe
they're stockpuck they're wrong because
it hasn't been disproven right and quite
they don't realize how wrong they are
right in fact they come at me and they
say brett can't even admit that he got
ivermectin wrong and it's like i don't
know what the hell you're paying
attention to you're still paying
attention to propaganda but here's the
point this is the system failure is all
about brett because the people you'll
talk about i know them you know them
what the [ __ ] is going on right but but
here's the point they're not stupid
people right but what they need to do is
go back and track their own thought
process yeah right if you thought well i
don't know what to think about lab leak
it is kind of suspicious that it was in
wuhan but the vaccine seemed like a
really good idea well okay now what
you've discovered is that we were
pressured on these two things and maybe
you think we were wrong on ivermectin
and maybe you think we're morally
defective and can't admit it or maybe
we're right and you just haven't seen
past the propaganda but if we got two
out of three right and you got them
wrong aren't you interested in whether
or not you might have the other one
wrong too and here's my point
i have a policy
from after evergreen
people come up to me periodically
and they say
this is not that common but it happens
periodically say i am so sorry i
misunderstood evergreen i thought you
were a jerk i thought those students had
a point it took me a long time to
understand what happened and i feel so
bad and i always say look you do not owe
me an apology so long as at the point
that you did realize what happened you
did the right thing
so i had a recent chat sit down with
james dellingpong on a deadlining pod
um and uh and it was a live audience it
was quite a nice gathering and stuff and
we had a chat like this but it was more
four miles in a three piece sorry didn't
dress up for you
but um you're in my studio though yeah
yeah yeah so it's more like a homeless
very nice um somebody tweeted me and it
was like they quote they quoted a clip
from the thing and it was like i missed
misunderstood magic all the way up until
this event that event was two weeks ago
right
and so there is a lot of this happening
but they're not the friends that i'm
talking about now now what i'm trying to
work out is we need them
of course they need to know we need you
guys man right it's not like i'm trying
to say you're a bunch of morons we don't
know no you know brett and you know me
right that's why i'm not naming names
but you know who i'm we need them
speaking yeah you're speaking because we
can't do it without them and we need to
learn the lesson of what happens
how do we become divided yeah yeah it's
possible to be analytically divided but
by the way i've never criticized any of
them in public right that's not my thing
man you mentioned this to me the other
day i don't do that man even if you
disagree me vehemently i never go for
you like if you're my friend i'll leave
you alone until you realize it for
yourself i think i've been very gentle i
have responded publicly because uh in
some cases the attacks have been quite
obviously i'm talking about friends
though right obviously i do speak in
public
of course of course even some of our
friends have said some things that were
pretty aggressive
and very personal yeah about you right
yeah
but nonetheless here's where we are
it's clear
that we were right about lab leak okay
and this isn't bad patting guys look at
they can read this isn't you just
backslapping and saying i was right when
you're not you were right
right and early and we're with you
together they come at you on the
together trial without them
i don't know if you've obviously spoken
about this on darkhorse but i just want
to say for the record systemic failures
of research methodology in that trial
that appear to be deliberate yes it is
you can't cite that at brett when it
comes to ivermectic it's an it's an
outright fraud right and and we can
establish it and the thing is if you
don't know what we're talking about ask
us we'll show you it's very clear but
nonetheless here's where we are two out
of three of these things have become
clear enough that you know that what
what you were being told at the
beginning by people like us was actually
right right this is not safe they've
told you it's safe safe means they know
it doesn't do harm they were wrong they
told you it was highly effective and now
they're telling you you need your fourth
booster they were wrong about that too
so
because ivermectin is the sticky wicket
this does give an opportunity for
our friends who got this wrong to
actually
step up at a moment that it still
matters
right and the thing is yeah so there's
an incentive there you're still a hero
well yeah i don't even
[ __ ] this hero [ __ ] you know i'll say it
because clearly some people are driven
by it right but nonetheless the point is
look
there's still good to be done
right you can still see what happened
this is a perfect place to learn what
the propaganda looks like because the
propaganda is still on that one if they
don't
well look we can't do it without them
yeah well we will have to yeah
we will have to but what we need
is a group that doesn't fragment over
trump or ivermectin or i mean so my
formula for this and that's why you see
me comfortably in all circles is when
you're looking at things in a macro
perspective like so if i've got a trump
support sitting in front of me that is
opposed to covert mandates and i've got
a corbyn supporter who i opposed
vehemently and obviously i'm not a trump
fan i say obviously i get accused of all
sorts of things right but basically i
defend trump where he's done where
people have so recently i tweeted out
the wall street journal article because
it turns out hillary clinton's own dude
mook campaign chief robin mook mook yeah
that's his name anyway turns out he
confesses yeah
hillary gave the order to make up this
russia collusion stuff and then the wall
street journal so i'm going to defend
the truth it's not defending trump right
likewise corbyn i opposed him vehemently
in this country he knows because he
lives here yeah i was one of the most
vocal
voices but if he's going to say
something right i'll say credit where
credit is due so what we've got to do i
just didn't think he needed to be pm and
anyway the system's corrupt so why was
he trying to be pms that's a different
story but what we've got to do is be
able to speak across the board to people
on where the agreement matters if this
is a death star moment then it doesn't
matter how you vote
it matters that you're trying to stop
technocratic slavery taking over and
that isn't hyperbole as i say look to
china and see what's happening right now
yeah not just the uyghur side of things
but the shanghai locked down on what was
going on there with the videos so what
matters to me more is not how somebody
votes yeah yeah to a certain extent some
issues still matter there like i don't
believe in you know that even even there
there are some well let's not go into
the distraction but there are some
points there we still need to feel
through but in essence we've got this
bigger problem here yeah now now we've
got friends that should understand that
point so it's why i'm on good terms all
the way through from reuben to sam
harris i've got no bad beef with any of
them on a personal level yeah even
though clearly they're on different ends
of the trump spectrum because you
mentioned trump so i give that example
and i could text both of them tomorrow
in fact sam and i texted through the
through the pandemic and ruben and i
texted through the pandemic right so so
there's no bad beef there with me and
anyone there out of our friends but
we've got friends that have these
different positions the difficulty is
unless you see it as a death star moment
you're not going to be willing to
transcend these differences because
you think they're the biggest
differences that are defining the future
of humanity at the moment you have to be
able to see it as a death star moment to
realize they are quite insignificant
compared to the risk of what we're
facing at the moment i would say they
are symptomatic yeah if you understand
that trump as a
you won't go crazy over it yeah yeah and
and and the fact that
super smart friends of ours are not
seeing that
i mean the only reason you think trump
is the biggest thing we need to be
discussing right now is if your ceiling
of of if your bird's eye perspective
sorry isn't flying where the eagle saws
but he's flying where the blooming
penguin is yep honestly yeah i don't
mean to be insulting yet but we've got
bigger problems so how do we get that
well this goes back to my principle
i will embrace anybody who does the
right thing upon the recognition that
they misunderstood the thing and and
have taken time to update that's fine by
me we're square if that's what you do if
you don't
then i'm sorry but you're not running
the idw protocol and
there is no point in trying to interact
that's finished man i mean that that
grouping is not gonna we've got to
because
the thing is i'm a business
cohesive group in the first place i'm a
believer in the protocol and you know
it's a prototype it needs an update but
um but nonetheless i a lot of people
miss it i miss it i'm going to say
something as well though again this is
not to take away any of the love i feel
from anyone yeah but the silence is also
not acceptable
not just the open disagreement which
you've had to face because i i've
thankfully people know me and they know
i haven't attacked anyone on this stuff
even if they our friends circles
obviously public figures i criticize all
the time that's my job um but if you're
a public figure and my friend then your
friend first that's how i feel right so
i don't go for them publicly they're
always going to be friends first even if
people don't treat me like that i don't
care they're my principles so so but the
thing is that even if you haven't you
face some of that criticism but even the
ones who haven't criticized the silence
itself such is the gravity of the moment
we're in that you must not be silent and
that that requires unpacking and the
only way you get there is you understand
what the gravity of the moment we're in
which is you get right you understand
where we are yes well i think
we have to leave plenty of room all the
room in the world for agnosticism it's
one thing to say i don't know what to
think about this it's very very that's
different right that
of course that's a natural place to land
but um you know the silence and hoping
it will go away has been very
destructive yeah
yeah all right well unfortunately i
think we're out of time which means
we'll have to do this again
man listen we can because um one of the
things i'm gonna do can i just end on
this point yeah so what the show that
you see there radical it's more of a
interview show for some of the big
topics or not what we just touched on
right for example i had on uh one of the
episodes coming out will be with mike
eden who was the uh senior most person
advisor on respiratory illnesses around
the world talking to me about everything
we've discussed why everything was wrong
right so that's more
you're the expert tell me yeah yeah
there's another show i'll be starting
soon no one has heard this yet you're
hearing it first on your podcast it'll
be a second show i'm going to kick off
which is a live
show
whereas the interview shows is currently
pre-record we'll get that live soon but
at the moment as pre-record this new one
which give me a month or so roll out is
a live format show which will be more
like a sit-down conversation but more
lifestyle topics
uh and that lifestyle weeks will include
politics yeah so but i'm saying it's
more relaxed like this kind of chat than
what i'm currently doing what i'm
currently doing is because we're
addressing like you know care home
deaths and you know victims whose
husbands have died or wives have died
it's a it's a heavy conversation whereas
this is you know you can have a more of
a coffee house conversation that's what
we're going to be starting and the
reason i'm telling you that is that's
what you you want to continue the
conversation you're welcome to join me
on that one and part two can be on on
that format would love to yeah does it
have a name are you not yet that's how
new is yeah yeah yeah okay
i mean that's easy to fix yeah the key
thing is it's going to happen sooner
because it's live streaming we don't
need anything we're just going to be
sitting here like this we'll put an ipod
there put the phone and just start you
know my my buddy brother long-term
friend you know say he's my brother or
mine you know osman raja who's also i
train mma with him
he came up through the uk bear knuckle
fist fighting scene in the old days
before ufc he's in the pit fights and
then he became one of the top coaches in
the country so he and i you know
basically he's going to be joining me
and it'll be that's why i say wellness
health lifestyle because what we touched
on at the beginning
when i said that you know whether it's
architecture whether everything touches
on this we've got to start pushing back
against the encouraged narcissism and
try and encourage community as much as
possible anyway so that's the show
awesome
well let me say this um i said this to
test laurie a couple days ago
nobody wants to live
in a foxhole
but the company in this foxhole has been
spectacular and i just want to say uh
it's been an honor to share a foxhole
with you absolutely man absolutely and
honestly it's been it's why i'm so happy
that we finally got to sat down because
it's been a journey through cobin and
you've had it hard man so we're always
here for you anytime you need likewise
all right love to heather yeah yeah all
right
you